[Music]
please god make this end
[Music]
if you're looking forward to santa you
won't like fauci's latest ranta
yeah if he can't find the grinch he'll
do in a pinch
dr anthony fouch is already trying to
cancel christmas appearing on face the
nation he let his inner scrooge out
but we can gather for christmas or it's
just too soon to tell
you know margaret we it's just too soon
to tell we just got a concentrating on
continuing to get those numbers down and
not try to jump ahead by weeks or months
and say what we're gonna do at a
particular time
and make sure your tree is wearing a
mask
pouch already walked back his comments
saying they were misinterpreted but if
you do gather for the holidays the cdc
recommends keeping six feet apart from
others and use window fans and open
windows to circulate fresh air
open windows in the winter that'll go
great in chicago
you either die from pneumonia or a hail
of bullets
but the pandemic might actually help you
save a few bucks if you're an intolerant
cheap a-hole a new survey by coinstar
found that one in eight americans would
not give a gift to a family member or
friend who did not share their same
coven views
the good news if you're filling out a
survey at coinstar you're too broke to
buy anything good
but we need to remind ourselves how much
of this is theater and virtue signaling
a video of a doj official recirculated
on social media if you can see that
showing him masking up when he thought
no one was looking and then only to
remove it just seconds later
wore it
[Laughter]
for approximately two seconds that guy
and this is happening all over the place
i was hoping that this would get better
but it seems like it's getting worse
bob that was the weekend good on you not
too bad watch squid game oh yeah i heard
it was good yeah helped the wife pretty
good in yours i don't want to talk about
it should we just go golfing i don't
know it's gonna rain i don't know we
could get a cart okay let's go right now
sounds good
cyrus it's as good as time as andy to
tell me are you what are you getting me
for christmas
the same thing you got me an autographed
picture of you yeah
ah re-gifting yes it's the new it's the
new thing that you know
as uh i sat
watching the uh
tampa bay patriots game last night and
heard the
crowd chanting brady brady i looked to
see that fouchy said we might not be
able to get together for christmas
where have you been bro
we've moved on without you
like no one's
we know there's sharks in the water
we'll look for the signs
but uh
new year's eve party at the crib
everybody i mean
[Applause]
we've moved on does that include me am i
invited yes you got to work the door
last time i did that at your party you
guys used me in the dwarf toss yeah it
wasn't fun yes
i don't know what i had to miss work for
that
it was a tough one congressman do we
need his permission to sell he's not a
you know what's interesting he's not a
leader he's a bureaucrat so he's never
ever going to say something that is
literally like he's always going to
hedge his bets that's what he does he
wants to be all up in everybody's
business
i mean he would have his way he would
have everybody replacing their elfina
shelf with everywhere there would be you
know fouchy on the couchy he would be
everywhere
and you know and you're talking about
now they want window fans yeah i mean
you point out chicago we're here in new
york right now i mean if you think that
how ridiculous that is in december you
imagine it at that cdc meeting they must
have had a hose connected to a car
muffler with exhaust fumes filling up
that room
it's insane so uh i actually do feel bad
for the uh the people who say they won't
give to somebody else like they listen
to fouchy they're reading the cdc
guidance and they're like you know what
they're so triggered by it i'm not even
going to be giving gifts to my loved
ones i almost feel bad for them because
you have to imagine that people aren't
giving
them gifts because they're such a
miserable human being right right yeah
you know what that's true it's like the
people that are saying that degan you
probably don't want them at your
christmas celebration or gathering i
don't know if you celebrate christmas uh
of course i do uh you always need
somebody at the table who you wouldn't
be upset if they got stabbed with a
steak knife on the back of the hand
yeah
my family will get that joke um
i but i just really quickly might have
to edit this but i thought i like it but
she's giving us a trigger warning on her
you might have to edit this but
but i think about why do they keep this
guy around and it's the old theory like
if you're an old you want an older
person around you so you look better by
comparison so a booze if you're a boozy
trollop
then you want a boozier more trollopy
person around oh yeah because you look
better
so cat understands i get it why are you
hanging out with kill me yes exactly he
is quite the boozy trollop yes
that's the name of his yacht by the way
the boozy trollop
things we do out in international waters
you don't want to know
right cat i showed you those pictures
once that was an iguana
yeah yeah uh indeed it was greg
you want to talk about that no no no no
uh what do you do what's your whatever
look man it's monday give me a break it
is monday it's the most monday monday i
don't know it just it's monday every
time this guy talks yeah
like i can't have any reaction to
anything that he says anymore except for
just
kay yeah
[Laughter]
all right buddy yeah i'm going to do me
yeah yeah listen to you yeah
if you don't understand that uh getting
risk down to zero is impossible then
you're not a leader every leader has to
everything we do entails risk driving
cars especially the most fun stuff yeah
but yes exactly hey we need to check
what democrats husband just bought stock
in window fans
all right i'm gonna propose that to my
dad in michigan we should do that see
what he says never been a better time to
buy a window fan hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else